est à présent monsieur jean Bizet pour
le groupe
UMP
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui à l'initiative du
Parlement européen qui remplit là
prélèvement le rôle qui lui est dévolué
par les traités une vraie négociation
est engagée entre le Parlement européen
et le Conseil sur le budget 2013 et le
cas de financier plus réel 2014-2020
comme toutes négociation et les longues
édifices mais pour la première fois le
budget européen ne se décide pas à huis
clos c'est un bon point pour la
démocratie c'est un bon point pour la
crédibilité des institutions européennes
et à ce titre nous tenons à saluer les
positions équilibrées et courageuses des
oraux députés en particulier celui du
parti majoritaire le Parti populaire
européen vous le devinez sous l'autorité
de son président Joseph Dahl d'abord
nous souhaiterions monsieur le ministre
connaître votre calendrier optimal dans
la négociation
visez-vous un accord sur le cas de
financier plus réel avant l'été comme
semble souhaiter la présence la
présidence irlandaise les conséquences
de la négociation du budget européen sur
la réforme de l'impact seront
importantes notamment en termes de
calendrier comment les anticipez vous
la nouvelle PAC entrea-t-elle en vigueur
là aussi en 2014
pourrait-il y avoir un accord politique
sur la réforme de la PAC avant le vote
définitif du cas de financier
pluriannuel par ailleurs le gouvernement
français a déclaré que l'essentiel de la
Pâque était préservé or ce n'est pas
tout à fait vrai puisque l'agriculture
dans son ensemble perd 52 milliards
c'est quand même pas rien et pour la
France elle-même la baisse est de 10% et
les pertes du premier pilier ne sont pas
compensés au niveau où vous l'aviez
laissé entendre ou plus exactement le
prénom de la République lui-même est le
ministre de l'Agriculture qui ont été
assez affirmatifs sur le sujet la
contrepartie n'est pas de 1 milliard par
an mais de 1 milliard sur 7 ans
dans ces conditions comment comptez-vous
préserver notre politique d'installation
des jeunes comment allez-vous soutenir
le verdissement auquel nous sommes tous
favorables mais qui nécessitent un
accompagnement des producteurs les
financements disponibles pour la gestion
des cris seront-ils suffisants les
agriculteurs français monsieur le
ministre ont besoin de savoir les
orientations d'un échéancier et d'un
budget clair je vous remercie de votre
réponse merci monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole
en 2 minutes à la fois vous parlez de
négociation du budget plus réannuel et
de la Pâque va être difficile donc je
vais aller droit à l'essentiel la
position de la France sur les demandes
exprimées par le Parlement européen pour
trouver un accord
fait que nous avons bon espoir
d'autant plus que la France a accepté il
y a quelques jours l'adoption du budget
rectificatif demandé par le Parlement
qui souhaitait en quelque sorte que nous
soldions les dépenses du passé dépense
estimées à 11 milliards 200 millions
d'euros après vérification des comptes
on est tombé d'accord sur 7 milliards
300 millions d'euros dès cette année ce
qui veut dire d'ailleurs que la France
va apporter un chèque de 960 millions à
l'Union européenne c'est sa code part en
quelque sorte par rapport aux dépenses
du passé et qu'aujourd'hui les
discussions avec le Parlement nous
permettent d'être optimiste sur une ABR
d'option du budget de l'Union européenne
sans doute à la session de ce mois de
juillet c'est une conviction évidemment
personne aujourd'hui ne peut dire avec
certitude que les choses se passeront
ainsi mais il y a une grande ouverture
notamment de la France pour trouver un
accord car dans le CFP il y a des
avancées qui pour nous sont essentiels
notamment la politique liée à l'emploi
des jeunes à la lutte contre le chômage
et s'il y a pas d'accord il y a pas ces
nouveautés et il y aura pas non plus de
plan d'aide alimentaire au plus démunis
si nous ne votons pas le budget par
ailleurs en ce qui concerne l'impact je
veux vous dire Monsieur Bizet je vous
garantis que pour la France le retour
attendu de la Pâques pour les
agriculteurs français sera garanti au
niveau qu'il a été obtenu sur la période
2007 2013 simplement il y a une
réaffectation entre le premier et le
deuxième pilier vous connaissez
excellemment ces choses puisque le
second pilier sera renforcé par rapport
à ce que nous obtenions par le passé et
le verdissement c'est quoi c'est toutes
les adaptations de la politique agricole
qui sont permis par le second pilier ça
veut dire quoi la rotation des cultures
les prairies permanentes les surfaces
d'intérêts écologiques comme les haies
ce sont des indications qui sont
aujourd'hui dans le règlement que nous
sommes en train de négocier en trilogue
et Stéphane Le Foll qui négociait encore
en début de semaine à Dublin dans un
réunion informelle m'a dit que nous
étions près sur un accord sur la partie
agricole dès cette année pour une
application au 1er janvier 2015 l'année
2014 était une année de transition merci
mon cher collègue jean Bizet
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
vos réponses je me permettrai malgré
tout sans ma liste de ma part considérée
que mes questions étaient claires vos
réponses étaient un petit peu moins tout
simplement parce que sur la partie
budgétaire vous avez parlé effectivement
de l'impasse de l'année précédente ou de
la période précédente de 11,2 milliards
d'euros et il n'y en a pour le moment
que cette virgule un ou deux et qui ont
été entre guillemets sécurisés donc il
en manque encore quelques-uns
deuxièmement ce qui concerne la
politique agricole commune je suis
désolé le compte n'y est pas si sur le
deuxième pilier il y a eu un rattrapage
à hauteur d'un milliard c'est un
milliard comme je l'ai précisé sur ces
temps et non un milliard sur je dirais
chaque année donc moi je considère si
vous voulez que les agriculteurs
français ont tout lieu d'être inquiets
parce que sur la période
2014-2020 et bien l'agriculture
française ne sera pas aussi bien
accompagné par les fonds européens que
sur la période précédente et que je dis
cela c'est tout simplement parce que
l'agriculture française se trouve si
confronté à une concurrence tant en
intra-européen par une augmentation de
plus en plus importante à la fois des
charges et des normes notamment des
normes environnementales je ne dis pas
que ça ne date que du début 2012 mais
c'est une accumulation qui commence à
devenir préoccupante et ensuite une
concurrence je dirais avec les pays
tiers parce que ceci correspond aussi à
un manque de compétitivité par des
charges au niveau des professions
agricoles très bien merci